welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's session pioneering our
understanding of the human brain is my
distinct pleasure to introduce to you
dr. George Ozaki dr. mazaki is the
biggest professor of Neuroscience at the
NYU School of Medicine an elected member
of the National Academy of Sciences in
the u.s. Academy repay and the Hungarian
Academy of Sciences he is the co
recipient of the 2011 brain prize and
among the top 1% most cited
neuroscientists he is also the author of
the seminal book rhythms of the brain
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. mazaki will be
presenting high resolution recording and
non-invasive perturbation tools for the
human brain my name is dr. Rebecca
shemune and I'll be your moderator for
today's session we are delighted to
bringing this educational web seminar
presented by Lavin's we would also like
to extend our thanks to the brain
initiative program directors in
particular dr. James mad for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by so
many questions during the presentation
so we click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type the question in the drop down
box our speaker will respond to your
questions by email after the
presentation the presentation is
educational and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. George
Rosati perhaps the best way to
communicate with the brain is through
closed loop interaction this is a very
simple idea
we need a biomarker which is an input
signal and we try to change that pattern
in the brain with some effective
mechanism here is a an outline how can
be how this can be achieved in animals
or in humans there is a factor ROM
there's an input on it has multiple
steps
and once the data are processed and we
have the the data available to trigger
something then we provide feedback to
the brain
now the afferent arm can be a variety of
different things so is the case with the
actuator arm in our case we decided we
would like to use NeuroGrid as the
afferent arm and transcranial electrical
stimulation as the actuator arm
NeuroGrid is a device which is which
looks like a piece of wrapping paper
it's conformable it's organic highly
hydrophobic so it sticks to the surface
of the brain and it is partly in sea
based that is perfectly compatible with
the Ennead tissue and the liquid excites
up you can see they are very small they
are grain they are neuron size they are
imprinted in this circuitry so the first
experiments we did was carried out in
rodents and you can see here in the
middle that both the bone and the doora
was removed and the gyro grid and this
recording size are placed directly on
the surface the recording size as small
as I mentioned they are neural size and
they are contacting the PR and through
the peer they are contacted the surface
layer of the cortex with this tiny
recording size we can record high
density in a local field potentials
multiple unit activity and occasionally
signaling the activity as facilitated
both from recordings to the neocortex
and in the hippocampus after removal of
the overlying tissue the same kind of
neuro grids we used also in humans
during surgeries and when epileptic
patients were implanted with electrodes
and you can see on the right side the
highlighted areas with in yellow that
even with this very high density the
resolution is very powerful
that spatial resolution and new parents
can be identified to see how these new
parents are useful for something we went
back to rodents and on a bee you can see
a high-density very large number of size
in these cases anywhere from from 180 to
256 recording size an amplifier on D
because you can see how this is the
slice you know get corresponds to the
bregma lump the distance and on E it's
visible that is how this confirmable
electrodes are placed from the surface
of the cortex with the help of this live
surface area NeuroGrid we discovered
that several parts of the neocortex have
fast oscillations that are reminiscent
of hippocampal ripples so we can call
them neocortical ripples on B if we zoom
in a little bit and we can see that
there are multiple different highlighted
areas in violet there are fast
oscillations in the frontal areas in
parietal areas and OC the this this fast
ripple oscillations are mapped and are
shown in red embedded or surrounded by a
green area which is the visual evoked
responses episode so on C we can see the
distribution of the this high frequency
ripple activity embedded on evoke
responses in response to visual
stimulation in green and some other
sensory stimulation in blue so what is
visible is that most of these peoples
happen to be associated with it areas
that are associated one by another with
the limbic system so indeed when we
compare how hippocampal activity and
prefrontal activity or parietal post
posterior parietal activities is related
to each other we find it's nice coupling
and the ripple frequency band in this
case about one hundred and forty Hertz
so we wondered what is the significance
of this ripple ripple coupling and we
did behavioral experiments where we
trained animal to learn hippocampus
dependent tasks
what we found is that the coupling
between the hippocampus and the
neocortex became stronger over the
course of learning this is illustrated
in B and also in D this was done two
years ago remarkably in the intervening
period just as of last week a paper
appeared in science and which was
basically the replication of this rodent
experiments in humans and what you can
see here is that that the medial
temporal lobe which is in this case
represent mostly hippocampal recordings
and the nearby cortical areas especially
the the the the sound making areas of
the cortex are very nicely coupled with
each other and this investigators showed
very nicely that whenever an item is
recalled from memory this is preceded by
coupling between hippocampal and
neocortical opposed so so much about the
efferent tom these are this this
Europeans are expandable they are
scalable large areas of the cortex can
be covered with this once we have
identified the patterns in the human
cortex in the future we have to take the
pattern and use it as a efferent arm and
see how it affects how we can affect and
modify neocortical activity subcortical
activity or any part of the brain the
choice we have for the the actuator arm
in our case is transferring electrical
stimulation
now transconductor care stimulation a
lot of high-quality
hypothesize the different mechanism some
of them are shown here the it they go
from stochastic resonance rhythm
resonance temporal bias of spikes
network entrainment or impulse patters
I'd like to show you two of these the M
temporal bias of spikes the network
entrainment because these terms are the
ones that are mostly visible in many
many papers on either clinical or
experimental use of transcon electrical
stimulation so in the example this is a
freely moving animal equipped with the
Transkei lactic or stimulation
electrodes the electrodes were placed
directly on the bone
rather than skin and current is applied
through these electrodes and what you
can see is that both the intracellular
trace and excess of the spikes can be
entrained by these applied forced
electrical fields in you know in a
freely behaving animal this is also the
case as it is shown on the bottom part
of the figure you can see that during
the stimulations times when it is the
sinus so it is seen on the on the left
the sinusoid stimulation at this low
frequency is capable of in training
neurons as well as it's capable of in
training the slow selection that happens
during sleep so we established in the
rodent that electrical stimulation is
capable of modifying electrical patterns
in the brain such as the slowest nation
so we transfer this idea to the human
use in this case we selected with the
collaboration with the Bedouin
neurologists friends collecting patients
with implanted grid electrodes these are
subunit electrodes you can see the the
patient's here and the distribution of
the electrodes the idea was that if we
can in train source oscillations maybe
those could be useful something
effective either in epileptic patients
or perhaps in the future in depressed
patients the first surprise was that the
well the first thing we have to do of
course is to establish the readout of
this alleged effect of this lower
silesia
in this case on the Left what you see is
that whenever there are up and down
states of sloths elations occurred
during the up state one can recognize
sleep spindles be used over and over and
over again and this one single patients
you can see that the sites that are
being entrained where the coupling
between slow oscillation and spindle
solution occurs is very large and very
large number of occurs and they are
consistent from night to night
now we would wanted to replace the
natural sloth selections by force
electrical trans-canada electrical
stimulation to our
surprise none of the over thousand signs
that we used and and at intensities that
has been used or that have been applied
in the great majority of transit
electrical simulation papers that is
anywhere between 1 to 1.5 volts or 2
milliamps was completely ineffective so
we wondered what is the difference
between a road and experiment and human
experiment so we went back to the rodent
experiment and try to establish what are
the minimum criteria if there is such a
thing that are acquired to stimulate
neurons from outside the skull to make
the long story short on this figure you
will see an intracellular recording
under anaesthesia and you can see that
we can either activate neurons or we can
silence neurons and in order to be
effective either for entrainment or just
just adjusting this the the timing of
spikes approximately 1 volt per meter
voltage gradient is needed that should
be applied near the neurons so of course
we cannot do it ourselves when XSL the
recordings a large number of within any
human patients at the moment
therefore we resorted to cut our brains
but you will see here in this figure
there are about 400 electrodes placed in
the caravel brain and we are applying
electrical currents to the skulls
directly or to the skin directly just
the same way how all these experiments
are done in the various laboratories
worldwide the the most important finding
that we we had in this set of
experiments is that a very large part of
the current is shunted away by the skin
and the soft tissue as well as the
Syrian resistance of the skull on the
graph and the bottom you can see that
about 80% or 70% 80% of the the the
current that is applied to the surface
of the disk up is is lost and the very
small ant gets actually into the brain
now we wondered how much electrical
field or how big the electrical fields
are
then we apply the currents that are
routinely used by many others in the
field and the answer is seen on the
right side so if you use about one
milliamp then the electrical fields that
are being in uses approximately 0.2 I'd
remember we need about one volt per
meter and in order to achieve that we
except related that we need about five
or more milliamp applied to the thread
through traditional electrodes to the
human brain so that's a large amount of
current that comes with a lot of
peripheral problems and therefore we
thought we have to modify our methods
and the way to modify our methods is the
use the amount of current that is
applied through the electrodes to the
scalp and try to increase the injected
current into the brain so my my
colleagues Mihai Marella coach as well
as Tony Murray he designed a novel
approach a novel solution which we
called intersectional short pass
stimulation which is basically not one
pair of electrodes but multiple
electrodes being used they are
stimulated with short pauses at a very
high frequency rotation just imagine how
this works you can record you can see
the dissimilarity of a human brain on
the left and right there are multiple
pairs of stimulation electrodes
simulation next was shown in blue and
red and the diagonal manner the one can
stimulate through one pair then next
another pair another private not a pair
and it's done it's a very high frequency
change so the advantage of this high
frequency stimulation is of course that
when we are stimulating at microsecond
range then the artifacts that are
affecting our recording system such as
EEG is miniscule is much much less than
when we are stimulating with the
reoccurrence the other advantages
for the future is that maybe through
adjusting the magnitude of the
electrical pauses we can direct the
currents into the brain and target areas
that need it for particular diseases now
what is shown on this figure is the
answer whether we can indeed effect
neural activity in the brain all these
subjects have their eyes closed and
therefore they induce for generated
occipital alpha oscillations of
oscillations are about one about ten
Hertz and we wanted to see whether this
the magnitude of the earth oscillations
can be biased by electrical stimulation
applied through the skull other to the
desktop through this new method the
intersection of short path stimulation
and the answer is yes but as you can see
from the increasing/decreasing magnet
you would have the applied currents that
it requires about four million in order
to have any impact any statistically
significant impact on the magnitude of
the of oscillation so to summarize the
actuate the part story here Trask
electrical stimulation is a nice and
good and effective way to bias neural
activity and even network activity
inside the brain the problem of course
is that how do we inject enough current
through the scalp without affecting
without producing a lot of side effects
such as stimulating the skin the retina
the vestibular system and even our taste
receptors which was most commonly what
most common complaint by the the subject
that they felt bitter taste so one
solution not the only one of course but
the our solution or our approach is
using intersection of past emulation
methods that allows us to reuse the
currents under the electrodes at one
particular site or particular parasite
but because the currents are because
they deposits are rotating at a high
frequency
the amount of current that
actually goes into the brain maybe
relatively higher the goal in at least
in our now experience is to have at
least one millivolt per millimeter or
one volt per meter voltage gradient
around the neurons it doesn't matter
whether they're human neurons or rodent
neurons but that's the requirement in
order to bias the spiking or the
membrane potential in order to achieve
that our recommendation is that at least
4.5 or larger or stronger the currents
need to be applied to the scalp finally
we would like to stress that our results
of course don't contradict the many
valuable and interesting experiments
that people have done with less currents
but we assume that those beneficial
effects or deleterious effects do not
actually achieve through affecting brain
activity directly but perhaps by
stimulating peripheral nerves that are
many of the window in the in the skull
so to summarize the the first in the
second part we started out the program
we are working hard on the neuro bills
and and we would like to apply them in
chronic recordings ultimately we would
like to get a biomarker for particular
patterns such as internet for spikes or
predictors of seizures and then apply
the fre after the afferent arm through
transguy electrical stimulation and see
how Ages or the consequences of interest
files could be diminished thank you for
your attention thank you dr. mazaki for
that outstanding presentation please
remember our speaker will follow up any
questions about his presentation by
email now I'm very excited to announce
dr. John Donoghue will be our next
speaker he will present merging minds
and machines brain computer interfaces
to restore movement and communication
for people with paralysis limit far to
see you there